uh tom daley ended his long wait for an
olympic gold medal alongside
mattie lee in a nerve-filled men's
synchronized 10-meter platform event
at tokyo 2020. it was a nail-biting
finale
with a british pair taking gold by just
one point from the chinese world
champions
it's matty lee's first olympics and he
can already say
he is an olympic champion well bursting
with pride i'm sure but ready to talk to
us here on sky news matty's parents
helen and tim who were watching at home
in the early hours of the morning
congratulations how does it feel to be
the mom and dad of an olympic champion
thank you very exciting and very surreal
actually still
at the moment but it's not really fully
sunk in just amazing
can't believe it i was going to see the
scenes behind you the bunting am i
looking at the remnants of the party
from this morning or just the beginning
yeah it's the remnants but they're
coming back yeah we're continuing this
party
have you had a chance to speak to matty
yes we spoke to him briefly um about an
hour ago
an hour ago yeah
how's he doing what did he say is it
sunk in yet
i'm not sure actually we didn't ask him
that he just seemed like his normal self
to be fair
just showing off his medal and very
excited um
and talking about what he'd been doing
since since the competition
i love that taking it all in his stride
and that pretty much sums up the final
for him and tom because
watching you could feel the tension
build those boys did not put a foot
an arm or a leg wrong they were so calm
and collected is that what mattie's like
in general because it was so impressive
not sure about generally but definitely
these days definitely out in his down
the diving board he does tend to be
quite calm and
and yeah and tim
what was it like this is matty's first
olympics
and he comes home or he will come home
with a gold medal is that something
he expected was he that confident
no i'm sure he wouldn't be he's not the
type of person to be that confident i
don't think
in the sense of thinking you're going to
come home with a gold no not at all and
i think he just wanted to go out there
enjoy the experience
enjoy the whole thing and whatever came
would be a bonus and he knew that we'd
be proud of him whatever the result
and obviously now we're just like like
statically proud i mean
can't believe it so
helen talk to me about his partner tom
daley because
he was actually matty's hero growing up
so it must be a real
pinch me moment for him not only winning
gold but winning gold alongside tom
daley
yeah absolutely no there's pictures of
him in 2009
um you know having his photograph taken
with tom daley and sort of getting his
autograph and things so
but to be honest um sort of since matty
moved down to london in 2018
they've become very good friends as well
as sort of synchro partners so i think
and tom's really helped him to to
progress in his diving so we're very
very very happy very pleased yeah
that's an understatement i'm amazed that
you two are so calm i mean
you know i'm feeling giddy and you know
i watched it and i don't even know him
this morning you're probably just
feeling a bit tired now but tim
helen referenced there uh matty having
to move down to london from leeds i mean
can we big up leads please getting all
these medals leads are
really high up the middle table um what
was it like for
for matty because obviously he has to
give up so much to get to this level
yeah i mean he's giving up a lot he
sacrificed a lot i mean say he's the
move to london with the sacrifice i mean
his
leads born and bred so going down to
london was a big move but
it was obviously the right move and the
right thing to do at this time in his
career so
um yeah it was good and helen there was
such a lovely tribute from tom daley
when they were talking
after winning that medal and there's
such a lot of pressure on him because of
his profile and his experience this is
his fourth olympic games
he said that he was feeling a lot of
pressure he said like he was going to
crumble at points and he
thanked matty for holding things
together
i don't think i've seen that interview
all that that sort of passed the
interview
such a funny morning this morning so we
haven't had a chance to re-watch it at
all so we're missing bits and pieces
that's very that's wonderful isn't it
that's a lovely thing to say
yeah there's such a great pairing what
next for matty i mean obviously
well hopefully he'll get a little bit of
a rest but timmy he'll go again won't he
this is just the beginning
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure yeah he's very
he's very much more um
i've lost the word now so geared up for
his diving he's very positive
and this is what well always what he
wanted to do but he's now really
enjoying his life enjoying his diving
yeah so he won't want to stop
no definitely not and helen what's the
plan for him when he gets home when you
get your boy home
well a big hug for starters because
we'll be wanting that uh but then we'll
we'll have some sort of family and
friends celebration
uh maybe maybe sort of next week or
something like that give him a chance to
to recover from the from the jet lag and
things and
helen and tim keep the bunting up and
the champagne on ice congratulations
very proud parents here on sky news
matty lee olympic champion thank you so
much
thank you thank you very much